throughout history the use of
mind-altering substances has been inter
woven with culture and human intrigue
whether it be the use of hallucinogenics
by ancient Greek philosophers the use of
opium for religious rituals by the
Mesopotamians the commonplace
recreational use of today or any of the
countless other examples it is clear
that substances that alter our
consciousness have and continue to
seduce the human spirit and there is no
sign of this slowing down but why is
this appeal so deeply a part of human
existence certainly there are a variety
of ways and reasons for which people
consume intoxicating substances but one
reason that is particularly fascinating
and seemingly common is the desire to
experience something foreign and
distracting from one's normal state in
general drugs and alcohol turn the
ordinary into the extraordinary the
mundane into something enjoyable
fascinating
or at least unique they create an
immediate and irrepressible distraction
from one's life and the inevitable
problems that might come with it when
intoxicated this sense of foreignness
redirects attention away from life's
problems and unto experiencing a high on
to comprehending and submitting to
something it is the same reason why
people exercise to a point of intensity
why the thought of lying in bed and
going to sleep can often sound like
heaven why people become hooked on
taking risks and chasing adrenaline
rushes because we want something that
requires our entire focus and attention
something to distract us
something to let us escape from our
perpetual stream of thoughts and
problems when I was a young child there
was a joke that my grandfather used to
say whenever I would get a mild injury
if I got something like a cut on my
ankle he would say if you want to stop
feeling the cut on your ankle I can
punch you in the arm and you'll stop
thinking about your ankle although this
was of course meant sarcastically there
is some truth in the fact that if
someone were to receive a feeling on
their arm they would not be thinking
about the cut on their ankle our drugs
and alcohol our way of self
administering this punch on the arm a
distraction from the cuts on the inside
maybe and maybe sometimes drugs are just
ways to explore more deeply into our
self and heighten our sensitivity and
appreciation for things in life
inevitably humans relationship with
intoxicants is complex not simply bad
and not simply good but what rings true
is that our everlasting relationship
with drugs and alcohol suggests that we
are still looking for something
something that we do not have inherently
or to get away from something that we do
Danny this isn't funny gonna untie me
buddy thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder